what do we want whether we are a  community a business or an individual we  want to be permanently connected fixed  or mobile indoor or outdoor it doesn't  matter  what we want what we need  is a continuous improvement of our  connectivity and by the way we are  shaping our business ways and our  lifestyles accordingly with no possible  way back on top we want that to be  cheap let's say affordable we want that  to be available for all and we also want  to preserve our environment in substance  we want to do more with less but to do  more with less  we have to choose the best available  technology  a technology that is enabling  performance reliability future  proof-ness and also carbon footprint  this technology is fiber in particular  for those choosing the fiber of the  highest possible quality